good morning John one thing I think
people sense but I don't say that often
is that I feel a pretty strong
obligation to do good and interesting
things with the tools that I have and
probably the two most impactful uh
things that I have easy access to are
one this audience this group of people
this community who have supported a lot
of very good and interesting things over
the years and then the second probably
most powerful tool is the people who
work at and the things that have been
made by complexly all of the things I
have been referring to as tools are
human beings but yeah I hope you
understand what I mean crash course in
particular has become a pretty
interesting thing in the world of
educational media which has resulted in
lots of people like knock it on our
doors to see if they can invest or
partner with us in various ways a lot
and to figure out what to do with an
asset like that all you really have to
do is to sort of understand the entire
problem landscape of all of global
education
so that should be fine but a few years
back we did decide to start walking down
a road like this and it did start with a
lot of trying to figure out what the
problems that students in the US in
particular face how to imagine those
barriers and how to lower them obviously
I don't know much about that I'm a
YouTuber with a background in
Biochemistry so it involved talking to a
lot of people who are actually in higher
education because we wanted to have a
kind of thing that sort of supported
people on their Bridge from high school
to college in the U.S so for a little
bit of context right now at a state
school it costs about twelve hundred
dollars for a three credit course you
can also get credits while you are in
high school but sometimes those credits
don't transfer indeed lots of these
credits don't transfer easily from
school to school and figure out when and
how they do is a big messy mess and that
is just one part of the big messy mess
that is the entire education bureaucracy
that is more complicated if you have
fewer resources and also you probably
have less access to information or fewer
people who are around you who've been
through the system before so as we were
doing our research we identified that as
actually one of the main barriers that
some people just don't know a lot about
how this system works and that can
result in costly mistakes the other like
main big barrier though which is the one
that people most often cite when they
drop out of school is cost it's just
that it costs a lot of money at some
point in the last five years some folks
at YouTube introduced us to some folks
at Arizona State University which is a
large public research University with a
specific goal of judging itself not by
like its rejection rates and how
exclusive they are but by how many
people they can include in their school
so after a lot of conversations and a
lot of work from a lot of people we
ended up with a thing that's called
study hall study hall has like four main
parts right now there's fast guides
which is like a guide to what different
college majors are about what they do
for you what people end up doing usually
once you get them how to college which
is just a crash course on how College
Works College foundations which are
videos that cover foundational college
courses that tons of people have to take
and finally a thing that just launched
this week at gostudyhall.com which is a
way of going from those College
foundations course to an actual course
that you're taking online that you can
get transferable college credit for from
Arizona State University the videos are
of course still free on YouTube but if
you want to take the course you start
out by paying 25 once you've signed up
and the course Begins the first one
begins on March 7th you could take the
class with a cohort of students with
faculty support and at the end of the
course if you think that the course did
a good job of teaching you and you like
the grade that you got you can pay 400
for a transferable college credit so
basically we're providing an option to
get foundational course knowledge and
transferable credits from a major
research institution with more
flexibility and at a lower cost and like
I kind of can't believe that's real the
goal is not to replace college with
YouTube videos it's to look closely at
the barriers and lower the ones that we
can I wish we could fix the whole system
with one sweeping action but as long as
we can't do that we gotta do what we can
with what we have so if you know folks
that might be interested in this please
tell them about it and of course thank
you so much to the dozens of people who
have been working on this in one way or
another for years now who are at
complexly or ASU or at YouTube I'm so
proud of the work that we've done and
I'm so excited to have it out there John
I'll see you on Tuesday
not making a video next week instead I'm
gonna get a colonoscopy so just so you
know that